قال لكريم لان واشنطن قادره ان ارادت على
دفع كيف للدخول في مفاوضات اشر الى انه في
الوقت الحالي من الصعب تخيل الدخول في
مفاوضات عامه مع اوكرانيا كما تحدث ان
واشنطن قادره على اخذ المطالب الروسيه
بعين الاعتبار المتحدث باسم الكريم بمتري
بسكوف اكد ان لا احد في روسيا يريد
استخدام السلاح النووي واضاف بان اهداف
العمليه العسكريه باوكرانيا ستتحقق عسكريا
او بالمفاوضات
وفي ظل هذه التطورات العسكريه هناك تساقط
اولي للثلوج ثلوج فصل الشتاء في الوقت
الذي تواجه فيه العاصمه الاوكرانيه انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي طبعا بسبب سلسله جديده
من الضربات الروسيه التي تستهدف البنا
التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
وفي هذا السياقه فدا تقريرا لصحيفه
الفاينشل تايمز البريطانيه افاد بان كل من
القوات الروسيه وايضا الاوكرانيه طبعا
يحسب خطواته المقبله بعد تراجع موسكو من
الضفه الغربيه لنهر دنيرو وما تعتبره كيف
نصرا قد يصب في مصلحه الروس الذي يعيدون
ترتيب صفوفهم ليش انه معركه ضاريه تركز في
الاتجاه الشرقي وايضا الاتجاه الجنوب طبعا
كل هذا وفق الصحيحيفه
تنفذ خرسون دخان القنابل الروسيه عنها ليس
شرقا نهر النيبرو الذي يقسم اوكرانيا الى
جزئين وانما غربها الذي انسحبت منه موسكو
وعادت ادراجها الى الشرق لتعيد ترتيب
صفوفها
[موسيقى]
هنا في الضفه اليسرى يحتفل الاوكرانيون
ويمزقون كل حرفين يخص روسيا لكن في الضفه
المعاكسه لا يبدو المشهد مشابها فخريطه
المعركه التي باتت تراها كيف بعد الترجع
الروسي بدايه نهايه الحرب احدثت فرقا في
فتنه العسكريه للهجوم والدفاع وفق ما نشرت
صحيفه
البريطانيه محللون عسكريون توقعوا ان تشتد
ساحه النزاع في الاتجاه الشرقي من
اوكرانيا اي انني قطر ساخنه تتركز في
اقليم بس تحديدا في تونس ولا سيما بالقرب
من مدينتي مخموت وافديكا اما البؤره
الاخرى فقد تشهدوا قصفا مدفعيا مكثفا في
الجنوب باتجاه مدن بحر ازوف كم مدينتين
بول وماريوبل الاستراتيجيتين وبالفعل دوت
صفارته الانذار بعد استهداف الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه
لاولي مره من سريعه
وبحسب الخبراء فان هذا الانسحاب قد يشكل
نقطه قوه للكرملين لان القوات ستعزز
وجودها على طول خط الجبهه الشرقيه وعلى حد
قولهم فانه سيكون لموسكل عدد الاكبر من
الجنود في كل كيلو متر مربع علما بان ما
يصل الى 50 بالمئه من الجنود سيعدو نشرهم
على مواقع دفاعيه
وبينما يخطط قاده الطرفين لاعاده التموضع
وتوزيع القوات ورسم خريطه المعركه فان
عوده الروس وفقا الفينل تايمز قد تصب في
مصلحتهم رغم انهم رحلوا تاركين حزمه
عسكريه مهجوره في خرسون لكن اوكرانيا
تعتمد على عنصر المفاجاه وهمها في الوقت
الحالي ازاله الالغام التي خلفها الروسو
على ارضهم
اسراء الصغير العربيه
على كل المال المزيد معي هنا في الاستوديو
مراسل العربيه في روسيا الزميل عبد الجواد
الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد اسمح لنا ابدا
بالتصريحات الروسيه المتعلقه بتحقيق
الاهداف هل نحن نعلم ما هي الاهداف وهل هي
معلن الاهداف الروسيه في اوكرانيا الان
لانه بالبدايه كانت مختلفه تغيرت خلال
الوقت اليس كذلك
واصبحت تتحدث عن ان استهداف مراكز الطاقه
والاتصالات هو هدفها الاساسي هذا الشيء
يحدث طبعا قبل بدايه يعني فصل الشتاء
القاسي في تلك المناطق ثلوج قد تصل بدرجات
الحراره الى 20 درجه تحت السفر
المتعلقه
السياسيه موسكو اطالت في سير العمليه
العسكريه خلال فصل الصيف تبحث عن وجود
حقيقي لها خلال فصل الشتاء باعتبار ان
عامل الثلج يعطيها دافع قوي في البدايه
طبعا الحديث يدور عن الجو المقاتلات
والطيارات والمروحيات هي قادره على على
العمل اكثر خلال فصل الشتاء باعتبار انها
مخفيه بعض الشيء بسبب الثلوج والامطار
والضباب والغيوم وغير ذلك
العسكريه الروسيه الثقيله لديها امداد
كبيره بما يخص قضيه الوقود بما يخصه
التجديد الاصلاح وغير ذلك على عكس الجانب
الاوكراني باعتبار ان موسكو تستهدف اليوم
معظم خزانات الطاقه التابعه للقطاع
العسكري ومنها خزانات الوقود الخاصه
والمختصه طبعا بقضيه المعدات العسكريه
والدبابات والمدرعات التي تدعم بجانب
المتوسط الغربي لاوكرانيا هل ستقف تنظر
الى الجانب الاوكراني يتقهقهر اذا المصحف
التعبير في فصل الشتاء طبعا موسكو من
الانسحابها الاخير كما سماه طبعا حسب
القراءه السياسيه هو انسحاب من تلك
المنطقه هو خساره لاراضي كانت موسكو قد
اعترفت بها بانها اراضي روسيه
جمهوريه واقليم من الاراضي الروسيه
الخريطه التي ترسمها موسكو اليوم لكن طبعا
الوضع العسكري ميسون على الارض يختلف كليا
عن الوضع السياسي اليوم مسكت تبحث عن عدم
فقدان عنصر الجندي لديها على ارض المعركه
وهذا ما دفع طبعا لنقل كميه كبيره قرابه
40,000 جندي طبعا القراءه العسكريه ترى في
ان هذا العدد كبير في ظل وجوده في تلك
المنطقه والمنطقه التي تفصله المسافه التي
تفصلها عن الجيش الاوكراني وصواريخ تقدر
بحوالي 30 كم لذلك طبعا القراءه العسكريه
ترى في نقل هؤلاء الجنود هو يعني اقل
الخسائر بما يخص هذه القضيه بحيث انهم
الان يعني يصلون الى مسافه بعيده عن
النهار تقدر ب 70 او 80 كم وفي
خلال فصل الشتاء هذا ما تقوله
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه تلك المناطق باعتبار
ان منظمات الدفاع الجوي تحتاج لمسافه 70
او 80 كيلو متر لاسقاط الصواريخ مصر قامت
بتفجير الجسور على نهر النيبر حتى لا
يتمكن الاوكران من عبورها والسيطره على
مناطق جديده والس- والسبيل الوحيد لهم
للوصول الى المنطقه الجنوبيه هو العبارات
ستهدفه ستستهدفها طبعا المدفعيه الروسيه
كما يدور الحديث في ظل طبعا الصواريخ
الروسيه التي تستهدف تلك المنطقه وقد تلحق
اضرار كبيره خاصه مع حلول فصل الشتاء
يعني السؤال التي سالته جزء من الاجابه
فيما يتعلق بقرصون كوننا اراضي روسيه ولم
تعد كذلك هل لا زالت هذه همم الخطه قائمه
على اساس انه بغض النظر عن التطورات
الحاليه الان في النهايه هناك عوده طبعا
هذا ما يتحدث عنه الروس اليوم هو انسحاب
تكتيكيكي كما يرون في الموضوع لكن طبعا
على ارض الواقع الجميع بانتظار ام المعارف
قد تكون خيرسون معركه استهزاف بالنسبه
للرؤوس هذا ما يراهم بعض
محللين بما يخص طبعا القراءه الغربيه
للقسا لكن على الجانب الروسي هي معركه
حقيقيه ذاهبون نحو اعاده خيرسون يرون في
هذا الانسحاب هو تكتيك نوعا ما لكن طبعا
على الارض الواقع الوضع يجري بموضوع اكثر
خاصه ان التعبئه الجزئيه ميسون كميه كبيره
منها انتقلت الى تلك المناطق وخساره
الجنود قد طبعا تدعو او تؤدي بالامر الى
استياء كبير داخل المجتمع الموجوده
او في الداخل الروسي على كلن جواد شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الاضافات بالنسبه لنا
وهذا الشرح كنت معنا في الاستوديو